it tells you how a graph behaves
okay based on what you know about the
first and second derivatives now let's
have a big rebus let's have a think
about this first three medium at the top
second review along the side this is a
very technical way of saying it and
we're still just getting used to it
right so why we put some language on
this okay when this first derivative is
less than 0 when it's negative what does
that tell you
she mentioned clear about the graph the
greatest negative right so an easier
like one word for that is it's
decreasing okay DBC yes
now when the derivative is equal to zero
so the dude is equal to zero what are we
saying what what kind of lame should you
use to describe that we would say it's
not going up and it's not going down
right so therefore it's stationary right
not moving and of course that's
decreasing this is positive so this is
increasing okay that's the first three
min now second derivative okay
instead of insanity again negative zero
positive this tells you instead of
gradient it's tell us about concavity
right so I guess we would say concave
down right that's concave down I guess
this would be concave up how do we
describe the middle one when the
secondary to zero zero guess we say do
it come happening right it's not one or
the other
okay no buts not some fillers in okay
let's think about just this one okay
it's decreasing so that means it's gonna
go from a higher value to a lower value
right and in fact all of the things in
this column you're gonna get from a
higher value to a lower value right but
how does it get fit well it's concave
down right phone cave down it's facing
down so this is the kind of shape you're
going to get to curved
okay can you see that decreasing and
concave down now let's think about this
one
decreasing and there's local cavity what
would that be but you had two
alternatives number one when you got the
arm sickening to me derivative being
zero we just saw that often that'll give
you a point of inflection right not
always but often okay so what would a
decreasing pointer deflection look like
well it would be concave up and then
it'd be concave down and at that
particular point right in the middle the
secondaries will be equal to zero okay
so yeah I am point of inflection but
that's not the only way to have a
decreasing function we're the secretary
is equal to zero okay because take a
line like say y equals minus X okay
you're differentiate once and you've got
a negative value which corresponds to
this but then you differentiate again
and sure enough you have no cacophony
which makes sense because it's a
straight line it's not curved one way or
the other
okay so this is not just a pointer
deflection this can also just be a
straight line okay
you see that's what American cavity and
studi creasing all right last one it's
still decreasing going from higher to
lower but it's facing upwards or I poke
them off so this is the kind of shape
that everyone okay now we'll fill out
this side the right-hand side we'll go
to the middle lost because the
right-hand side this is the reverse
of the left hand side this time I'm
increasing and I'm concave down so I'm
going from lower it's a high up concave
down so be a mirror image you see that
this will also be the vigorous you've
got your straight line okay it's
increasing with no concavity or you've
got another kind of reflection lastly
this again it's a another mirror image
now what happens in the middle this is
the fun if you have a stationary point
right and it's concave down we just
looked at Co cavity as a test for
whether some things are local Max or
they come in so which one is this it's
it's a maximum right
okay maximum turning point let's do this
one cuz easier then we'll go into the
middle if it's concave up and you've got
the dream being zero then it's going to
be a minimum okay now what happens in
the middle we're just looking at this
example right if you've got a stationary
point and it's a point of inflection at
the same time what kind of point could
have been right we call that we call it
a horizontal wait a min flexion now by
the way that's not really kind of
horizontal put it flexure you can have
right you can have it the other way yes
so this is above horizontal Quinn's
infliction okay the first term is your
so you draw a horizontal tangent through
it but there's also a change in
concavity if this is concave down then
up and this is up there down okay yeah
like this Y X to the fourth that's true
so you've got counter examples to this
but this is the general path you would
have to prove you have the test the
second derivative on either side and
then you'd be leopards concave up and
then it's concave up so still a
stationary point but it's a lot of put
inflection because there's no changing
from cavity there's one last thing I
missed out remember we had these
straight lines here right because
straight lines I by definition they have
no concavity right so I also have a
straight line here what kind it should
be horizontal because the derivative the
first year would be zero
okay so there's our family folks I
suppose if you like you could include
this guy yeah that's X to the four right
because that that was the care example
we looked after and to the station so on
and so on because there are so many
regards and they're the exception and
that's why I've got a cream this is the
general idea okay this is the general
idea yes what you're actually because if
you think that takes a hundred it is
still actually growing very hard right
what happens is all of these even powers
right x squared X to the four and so on
all the way up to here you can see they
all go through a common pair of points
they all go through one one you see that
because one matter hundreds to one right
but what happens is your parabola might
look like this and then X to the four
will be fat up but it's still good to
one one and then next to the six we've
fatter but still goes through one one
and eventually you get like this kind of
shape and no one does that make sense
okay so these are the kinds of shapes
that you get if you if you go and
increase the power